so andy how do you think you're going to
feel going out there to defend your
title is it going to be quite
nerve-wracking
yeah i would expect so i mean i'm
expecting to feel nervous i'm expecting
to feel yeah some pressure
um
but yeah i i i hope i hope i enjoy it i
mean it's something i'll i may never get
to experience again
and you know from hearing players talk
about it in the past and i've spoken to
emily
about it as well that you know that
everyone enjoyed it and you know thought
it was just yeah it's a it was a great
moment the first time they did that so
i'll try to enjoy it if i can
do you think it might be quite emotional
you're gonna get such an amazing
reception when you walk out
yeah well to be honest again i i don't
know until i until i walk out there i
mean it could be
but yeah
it's it's just a new experience for me
is something i've never had to deal with
before so i don't know how i'm going to
respond to you know whether for me it
will be emotional nerve-wracking
enjoyable
i don't know but we'll find that on
monday
do you think much about
what you achieved last year what an
amazing achievement it was
i did uh like
for the sort of month month or two
afterwards you know i thought about it
um quite a lot but
after i had the surgery on my back not
really um i haven't thought loads about
it until i came back to the grass courts
and then i was getting asked about it
you know a lot you know i got asked
about last year's final the last game
and
you know obviously what what what's what
it's going to be like coming back as
defending champion but i haven't thought
about it that much uh this year have you
watched it i've watched the last game uh
i've watched the last two or three games
um
once or twice but i've seen the last
game uh
probably 9 ten eleven times but i have
not watched the whole match and how does
that make you feel when you watch it i
still feel nervous to be honest watching
it now uh
you know just because of the way the
game went it was the last game was i
don't know it was 12 minutes or 30
minutes or something and
the way that it went is obviously a
nerve-wracking game for me it was a very
stressful game the hardest game i've had
to play in my career so
yeah it's still nerve-wracking to watch
didn't there's less pressure on you this
year because you've done it now
i think probably from a media
perspective and you know public
perspective then yeah there might be a
bit less pressure but
i think it's also important to remember
the pressure that athletes put on
themselves
to perform well and you know wimbledon
is one of the main reasons why
we train hard spend time in the gym and
on the practice court and
for for those moments to play well in
those moments so i put a lot of pressure
and expectation of myself to to do to do
well and perform well there and that
will still be the case when when i start
the tournament do you still want it as
much
yeah well it's it's different um
because i've never i'd never won
wimbledon at this point last year but
now i know what it's like and a lot of
people have said
you know for the few months afterwards i
found it hard in terms of motivation
but once you have achieved something
like that you want to try and do it
again you want to give yourself an
opportunity to try and do it again and
hopefully i can put myself in a position
to do that your results at wimbledon
have always been so consistent do you
always back yourself regardless of the
position you're in in any match on grass
to win it because you do have the knack
of of playing well on grass yeah well
wimbledon
has been my most consistent tournament
in my whole career i've played my my
best tennis there i would say
um
and yeah i've improved their
most years um i've played i've learned
from the experience i've had from the
losses i've had and
yeah i've come back in a lot of matches
when i've been behind there and
you know when the the supports like it
was the the last couple of years it
makes a huge difference in the matches
um and i'll i'll try and use that again
this year
so you've had a bit of time to work with
emily how's that going and how are you
getting along yeah i've i've loved it so
far i've really enjoyed having her
around we spent five days on the court
now we practice on sunday
um every day through until
thursday obviously today and uh yeah
it's been it's been great uh we talked
we had dinner last night and spoke about
you know coming back as defending
champion and how she handled it and
things she did well and didn't do so
well
so that's definitely something that she
can you know help me with over the next
couple of days
and then yeah the practices we've had
have been good fun i've enjoyed being on
the court and that's
that's very important you know i've
worked hard
prepared well and i've enjoyed it so
have you actually hit with her
we're gonna hit tomorrow uh i'm only i'm
having a light practice tomorrow so
that'll be the first time we've hit
together she's gone off this evening to
get some grass court shoes and some
whites so to practice yeah she's gonna
have some balls tomorrow